so Steven were you thinking about going  to college dad you know his name is Zack  I miss Stephen you know Stephens going  to Yale next year dad why are you doing  this  what am i doing dad you know exactly  what you're doing Zack is an artist he's  an artist yes he's an artist  Renato accountants like you so you're  sold the money dad what the hell is that  supposed to do you have to start  exercising more you have to go on a  rigid diet oh no Sophie  am i doing anything this weekend I was  wondering actually I'm meeting my  boyfriend's parents for the first time  I'm so excited to move in here and then  we're going to this place in Malibu  called the Paradise Cove have you ever  been  yes see these new headphones yeah those  are cool but why did you spend $300 on  headphones I mean honestly you can get  the free pair with your phone did you  pay your rent yet I mean do you even  know a dr. Dre song say one lyric I  think you're using your imagination more  than the headphone